so then my dad finishes and we go to the
bar so he's like do you want a beer
and I was like yeah sure I'll try and
like that was my first little nasty
little treat right right yeah slide me a
sudsy one
yeah I felt like a little [__] for some
beer yeah you're like give me that foam
give it to me I see him at the bar he's
ordering the beers and then he turns
around and he's holding two Guinness
that dude just did an Iron Man and he's
like okay dude you want beer now we're
not drinking piss you said beer so he
was like of course I thought you liked
dark beer and I was like yeah but
all I've been picturing is like a light
crispy [__] Bud Light Lime damn dude
your dad just low-key calling you a
[__] no he did